الرغبه في التطور التكنولوجي والاستغناء
عن التدخل البشري تتزايد من قياده ذاتيه
للسيارات والقطارات وصولا لجدليه تسير
رحلات جويه بقياده ذاتيه وفقا لموقع
اكسيوس لم يعد السؤال الابرز هل سيكون
ممكنا بل متى سيصبح متاحا
المنافسه على تسيير رحلات جويه ذاتيه تشتد
بين شركات الطيران المدني الكبيره
ايرباص اعلنت عن اختبار مجموعه من انظمه
الطيران المستقله تدعى دراجون فلاي لتمكين
الهبوط التلقائي في الاحوال الجويه السيئه
والتعامل مع حالات الطوارئ فيما اعلن
الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه بوينج ان مستقبل
التحكم الذاتي في الطيران المدني اصبح
حقيقيا اما في مجال الشحن الجوي فاصبح
الامر واقعا والمنافسه بين شركاتها تاخذ
منحا اكثر جديه شركه الناشئه حصلت على عقد
للعمل جنبا الى جنب مع اداره الطيران
الفيدراليه ووكاله ناسا فيما وقعت شركه
ناشئه مماثله تدعى صفقه لبيع 20 طائره شحن
عن بعد
كلما اتخذت خطوات نحو التقنيات القياده
الذاتيه للطائرات المدنيه تزداد مخاوف
الطيارين من توجه شركات الطيران نحوها
للتخفيف من الاعباء الماليه والتوظيفيه
وهو ما تطلب بيانا توضيحيا حول مخاطر
الخطوه من قبل اتحاد طيار الخطوط الجويه
من الضروري وجود طاقم طيران مكون من شخصين
على الاقل لاداره عبء العمل على سطح
الطائره والحمايه من احتمال عجز طيار واحد
اما الحلقه الابرز في رحله الاعتماد على
رحلات جويه مسيره ذاتيا فهي الراكب والى
اي مدى قد يكون السفر على متنها امرا
مقنعا بالنسبه له
علي السمان العربيه